last couple of talks let's
welcome thanks Rasmus thanks to all the
organizers for inviting me to give this
talk uh and thanks to all of you for
sticking around till the
end so um I'm going to be talking about
this general area of uh algorithms for
network
unreliability uh and um I I structur the
talk mostly as a survey so I'll I'll
talk a lot about uh of the general area
and what's known and what's not known
hoping to get you excited to maybe some
of you at least to work in this area uh
but towards the end of the talk maybe in
the in the last third of the talk I'm
going to be talking about a specific
result I can get this
[Music]
to
okay so I'm going to be talking about a
specific result in the uh last part of
the talk uh and that result is uh with
rosu Chen who is my PhD student and and
he is here he has been here for the
entire semester hope some of you got to
interact with him uh William ha who was
my undergrad student uh and now is a PhD
student at CMU uh and Jason Lee who many
of many of you know he was a post or is
a post dooc at the Simons Institute uh
is going to be starting as an assistant
professor at CMU in a few
months all right so what are we going to
be talking about what is this uh what is
this thing called Network unreliability
or network
reliability and it really is about
asking this very basic question so
what's the role of a network in general
no matter what the application is the
role of a network is to connect right it
connects individuals it connects
entities uh it connects networks uh but
so it's very natural for us to ask how
robust are those connections whatever we
manage to connect using the network how
robust are the two-edge failures because
all networks no matter what the
application is suffer from failures from
time to
time uh and this general question
applies to a broad range of applications
it's really ation agnostic so whether
you are looking at a network for a a
circuit on a chip or a communication
Network or or a road Network or any
other kind of network this question
broadly makes makes a lot of
sense now in this particular talk I'm
going to restrict myself to just
undirected networks of course the broad
question also makes sense to directed
networks but for the purpose of this
talk I'm going to be
only focusing on undirected Networks
now in order to make this question
concrete and sort of get specific
problems out of it uh I need to tell you
what I mean by robustness what kind of
properties am I looking at in the
network and I also need to tell you what
is my model of edge failures how do they
fail okay so in terms of defining robust
robustness there's really a very broad
range of problems that people study I'm
not going to go through all of this list
right now but in a couple of minutes
come back to this list so there's a lot
of different connectivity properties
that you might want to preserve in your
network under Edge
failures but what kind of edge failures
are we talking about traditionally we
always focus on worst case failures okay
so we want to say what's the fewest Edge
failures in a worst case sense
adversarially chosen
edges that are required to disrupt
whatever property connectivity
robustness property I have in my Network
okay so let's take an example so let's
take the first robustness property it
says that a graph I all the vertices of
the graph remains connected okay that's
is a very basic property I might want of
my network and I want that property to
be preserved under Edge failures so if I
look at the global mincut problem what
that's asking is what's the minimum
number of worst case failures that will
disrupt that property what's the minimum
number of edges that I need to take out
in a worst case sense until the network
gets
disconnected similarly you can look at
the second property so it says okay so
maybe what I really care about is not
the entire network staying connected but
a particular pair of vertices s and t
staying connected that's what I care
about in my application and then again
you could ask what's the minimum number
of edges again chosen adversarially in a
worst case way that when removed when
they fail SNT that particular paer gets
disc connected okay and that's the
minimum STD cut problem so in this way
most of the problems that we study in
graph connectivity can be modeled in
this manner where there's some property
that you want in your network and you're
are asking okay so what's the worst case
failure what's the minimum number of
failures of edges chosen in a worst case
way that will disrupt my property and
that's what I want to figure out okay so
that's that's what's been studied a lot
over the last 50 years what I want to
talk about today is a little different
in terms of the failure
model and the difference is this so
instead of asking about what happens to
a network if there's a worst casid set
of edge failures what I want to talk
about is what happens to a network when
there's a random set of edge
failures okay so I'm no longer asking
for uh worst case minimum number of
failures that that disconnects my
network I'm saying let's say every Edge
fails in some random way now is my
network connected or not okay and what's
how do I distinguish between a robust
network from a
non-rust so let's take this and and make
this a little more concrete so that uh
we can argue about
things and and and in fact even before I
I make I give you the concrete
definition let me say a little bit about
why do I care right why do we care about
random Edge failures uh now one very
natural reason for caring about random
Edge failures is that in many
applications in many situations in
practice that's sort of a better model
for how a network fails right so if you
think of a road Network it's not that
some adversary is coming and clogging up
some roads what's really happening is
certain roads with some probability fail
uh now of course this is you can we can
keep arguing about whether what the
precise Rand model is and what kind of
dependence you have and things like this
but at least there's some it seems a
reasonable model to
study it's also the case that a lot of
different fields have converged to this
and have called so there are all these
different books which talk about both
models as well as properties of random
uh of graphs under random failures so
it's a very well studied Topic in an
empirical practical sense
but if you look at algorithms there's
hardly anything known so we know very
little about algorithmic results for
what happens to a network under random
failures this is distinct from saying
something about combinatorial extremal
results so in in an extremal sense we
kind we have of course there's a lot of
study of random graphs so we know
something about what happens in random
graphs but you'll soon see what I mean
by the lack of algorithmic results yeah
that's that's at least one motivation
for why why I want to study
it okay so now now let's let let's make
this concrete so I've been sort of
waving my hands and giving you some
general ideas of what I want to talk
about but let's now make this a concrete
set of
problems so I have some input graph okay
this is some arbitrary graph on
nvertices and M
edges and my failure model is the
following every Edge in the graph fails
independently and identically with the
same probability P okay now you could
argue that in many
situations it's more reasonable to say
that different edges fail with different
probabilities it turns out it's not very
different from so it's it turns out that
you can actually simulate those
situations using this uniform model at
least unless there are like very extreme
uh parameter values so let's not go into
that let's stick to this very simple
uniform model so I have a graph every
Edge fails with some probability P what
I get out of this process is some random
graph G of p and I want to argue about
this graph I want to understand how
robust this graph
is in particular the algorithmic
question given the graph and given the
value of p is the following I just want
to estimate the probability that this
random graph G of p is robust in
whatever sense of robustness I want to
study okay and again there's all these
different definitions of robustness as I
said that we might be interested in so
we might be interested in okay so this
random graph G of p is it connected or
this random graph G of P does it connect
a particular pair of vertices s and t or
various other things now in order to
keep things focused and also because
there's very little known in in this
area I'm going to really focus on just
these first two problems okay so let me
write those problems a little more
clearly so one problem I'm going to talk
about is the single pair Network
unreliability problem so this problem
ask the following I give you a graph
every Edge fails with probability P find
me the probability that s and t a
particular pair of vertices in My Graph
are connected so that's problem one
problem two which is going to be the
bulk of my talk today is very similar
except that I don't give you a
particular pair of vertices S and T I
give you the graph I give you this value
p and I ask you what is the probability
that the graph G of P after edges are
failed with probability p is connected
or disconnected okay I mean of course
these two are related whether it's
connected or
disconnected so is this is this problem
space clear any questions about the sort
of General definitions of problems that
we are going to talk
about
okay good so that's our problem and
here's a very uh sort of sequence of
works in the late 70s early 80s that
established the following eventually so
it says that both of these problems the
single pair and the all terminal Network
on reliability or reliability problems
these problems are both all of these
problems are sharply hard okay in fact
sharply
complete so really we don't don't expect
that we can precisely exactly compute
these
probabilities and in fact this last
paper the paper due to Prov and ball uh
that said something more it said that
it's not only sharply complete to find
these exact probabilities but it's also
sharply complete to find approximate
probabilities where the approximation
factors are some parameter Epsilon the
only catch is that they allowed in their
in their reductions they allowed Epsilon
to depend on the size of the network so
in particular Epsilon was exponentially
small in the in the size of the input
graph okay so that's that's a result
they got and in their conclusions uh
they write that we should note that a
seemingly more difficult unsolved
problem involves the case where Epsilon
is constant I it is allowed to vary it
is not allowed to vary as part of the
input so that that was the sort of very
early phase of work in this area and
that established this problem the
problem where you want to uh want to
find the approximate the value of
reliability or on reliability up to a
constant let's say up to a factor of 1.1
uh efficiently that problem was left
open by this early
work all right sorry uh I'm
question what about Paul no sort of
intuitively I I I think I know of some
applied people who would prefer Epsilon
to be a small
polinomial yes so we'll we'll get to
that soon okay yeah we'll
yeah so we'll get to algorithms that can
handle that
case all right so and and that's where
the story sort of ends with the single
pair Network reliability problem okay so
we till now we haven't resolved this
question so if I even gave you Epsilon
to be a constant there is no efficient
algorithm that can find uh let's say 1.1
approximation to that single pairer
Network on reliability
andil it applies both to reliability and
unreliability yes sorry and is this an
additive or an multiplicative
approximation uh let's say
multiplicative let's say even a fixed
constant 1.1
approximation okay I mean this
particular result the Epsilon was
additive but but the one that's like
wide open is can I get a 1.1
approximation you had a question I'm
just this can only be true if the actual
probabilities are exponentially
small so yes yes we are going to yeah
sure sure we are going to we are going
to talk about it you're
right okay any other
questions
okay so the rest of my talk is going to
be about the all terminal Network
reliability unreliability or un
reliability problems so this is
basically the problem where again I give
you a graph just and every word Edge
fails with some probability P you can
even think of p as half it doesn't
really matter and I want you to figure
out what is is the probability that the
graph gets disconnected or what's the
probability that the graph stays
connected and of course these two are
the same if you're talking about exact
numbers but we are approximating
things okay so so these are the two
parameters we are interested in
reliability and unreliability I'll call
them r and u respectively and as I said
these are equivalent in terms of exact
computation U is just 1 minus r uh but
if we are looking at multiplicative
approximations which is what we going to
do today then these are these are
different problems in fact I I'm going
to focus on one of them and I'll briefly
say what's known for the other one and
the techniques that go into the two are
very very
different so at this point the next
phase of research in this tried focusing
on special cases of this problems so
carp and Luby in uh 1985 they gave an
algorithm that estimates or approximates
the unreliability parameter uh but only
applies to planar graphs and in a model
where the expected number of edges that
fail is is not very large it's like uh
order
login okay so it's a it's a very sort of
specific result about a particular class
of graphs uh and then about 10 years
later Alon free and Welsh uh they
studied the reliability problem so you
want to approximate reliabil
but they started it in only in dense
graphs where the minimum degree of every
vertex is n and again gave an
approximation algorithm for that case
okay now I should mention that this last
result is sort of a corer of something
broader like they looked at a broader
class of dense instances of problems and
this just falls out as a
COR so the first general purpose
algorithm for this problem and I'm
calling the first generation of
algorithms for the problem we'll see
there are subsequent generations of
course that's why I'm toing it the first
but the first algorithm that gave
without any conditions on the input it
gave a fully polinomial time randomized
approximation scheme for estimating the
unreliability of the graph it doesn't
work for reliability only for
unreliability uh and that was due to
carger in in
1995 so let's let's just go over exactly
what this algorithm does so you it an
Epsilon it will give you a 1 plus
Epsilon approximation of the value of
unreliability so how unreliable the
graph is what's the probability it will
disconnect it'll do that in time that's
polinomial in n and Epsilon it's a fully
polinomial time approximation scheme so
that addresses rasmus's question even if
Epsilon is inversely polinomial in N
this algorithm Still Remains polinomial
time it is a Monte Carlo algorithm so
there will be some small chance that
that the algorithm will fail and give
you some junk but that probability is
going to be one over polinomial in n and
the algorithm runs in time something
like M * n the 4 okay so at that point
of time the first algorithm the goal was
to just get a polinomial algorithm it
wasn't so much to optimize the
right and then about uh
sorry almost 20 years later uh Harris
Harrison trason
who basically took the same algorithm
with some mild modifications but did a
much better analysis of the algorithm uh
they showed that indeed the running time
of the algorithm is about n cubed so the
previous results says the running time
could be something like n to the six
this drastically reduces it to a little
over
at any questions about just the
statements yeah epon Str is not appear
in the run time am iing something yeah
so these there are poly one over Epsilon
terms which I'm which I'm suppressing so
thing of Epsilon is
point1 other questions Alo this like
better analysis doesn't depend on the
edge this uh n n Cube what's dependence
on the edges where it's not depending on
that at all it's not because the number
of edges is I'm assuming is bounded by
Pol like bounded by n cubed if the
number of edges is very large then like
as in like you have a lot of parallel
edges for instance okay then there will
be some linear
terms but let's assume for now
that any other
questions okay so what's going on so
what's the what's the main idea
here so here's maybe the a very simple
but key observation so the observation
is just this so when does a graph
disconnects so I'm randomly failing
edges with probability P if the graph
has to get disconnected as a result of
this process it must be the case that
all edges of some cut have to must fail
right if in every cut at least one Edge
survives a connected graph will remain
connected that's that's just a basic
simple fact but now that you have you
have explicitly stated this you can use
this to think of this problem in terms
of Boolean formulas in the following way
so what you do is you define a Boolean
variable let's say x a y that's an
indicator variable for whether the edge
e subi fails so X subi is one with
probability p and one minus p with
probability uh and zero with probability
one minus p and all the x sub y are
independent every Edge is failing
independently okay so you define this
Boolean formula Boolean
variable so now we can say that the
disconnection of the graph of the random
graph corresponds to the following dnf
formula so this dnf formula takes each
cut in the graph and represents the cut
in terms of a conjunction so you take
the first cut you want you enumerate all
the cuts in whatever order you want take
your first cut look at all the edges of
the cut and write a Boolean formula
that's the and that's the conjunction of
the variables for all those edges
so note that if the edge fails then all
these variables are set to
one so any term in this Boolean form in
this formula evaluates to one if the
corresponding cut
fails now as we argued on the first line
the entire graph gets disconnected if
some cut fails in the graph of course
multiple Cuts can fail but at least one
needs
to so the failure of the the
disconnection of the
graph corresponds to this Boolean
formula evaluating to True right this is
an exact
correspondence so determining ugp the
unreliability becomes a question of
figuring out the probability that this
Boolean formula evaluates to True when
we set every variable to True with
probability P
independently okay that's the that's the
basic equivalence so if you here's an
example Le so I have like four edges
here let's look at just one cut let's
say the cut that contains the edges E1
E2 and E3 that's a cut in the graph so
I've written This this term X1 and X2
and X3 so if all of those variables are
one then this cut on Top This cut will
fail and you can you write this for
every cut in the
graph great so I have this so what do I
do with this so I now need to evaluate
the probability probability that this
formula is
true and here's a beautiful theorem
maybe some of you have already seen it
this is a classic result so this is due
to carp lubian Madras and it says that
give me any Boolean formula I don't care
what the formula looks like there is a
fully polinomial time approximation
scheme for estimating the probability
that this formula will evaluate to True
when every variable is set to True with
probability P okay so exact what we want
if you give me a Boolean formula give me
a probability for each variable
evaluating to true this algorithm says I
can get you an approximation of the
entire prob formula being
true okay so it seems like what I should
be doing is writing this formula out the
one that I wrote on the previous slide
I'm calling that the cut formula and
then just apply this result what's the
catch yeah it's too big formula is just
too big because I have an exponential
number of cuts in My Graph and so I can
do this but how do I deal with the fact
that I have too many Cuts right I won't
be able to do this in polinomial 10 so
that's what we need to overcome we need
to deal with an exponential number of
terms in the cut
problem any other questions at this
point okay so the main idea in in this
word by carard that deals with this
issue is the following it says that when
a reliable Network fails and by reliable
Network I mean a network that does not
really fail very often right the
probability of failure is small
probability of disconnection is small so
when a reliable Network fails it almost
always does so so because of a small cut
so I'm not going to prove this but but
it's intuitively clear what's going on
so a graph has a lot of different cuts
small cuts are more likely to fail than
large Cuts every Edge is failing with
probability P so small Cuts in general
are more likely to fail than large Cuts
however there are few small Cuts there
are many large Cuts in a graph so this
says that if the overall failure
probability is small enough then the gap
between small and large Cuts failing
becomes large enough that large Cuts
become unlikely to fail it's really a
small cut that will cause your Gra
disconnect okay that's that's sort of
morally what this statement is
saying and if you are like in terms of
precise numbers it says that when the
reliability is less than unreliability
is less than something like n to the
minus 4 some polinomial inverse
polinomial then the probability that a
cut of value greater than twice the
minimum cut failing is really tiny
compared to the overall unreliability so
I can I can basically ignor this event
this event is going to be absorbed in my
approximation so as long as
unreliability is smaller than 1 / n the
4 I can ignore everything except the
edges of size at most twice the minimum
cut of
the okay okay so that means that what I
can do is I can take my cut formula I it
has an exponential number of terms but I
truncate the cut formula at only the cut
of value at most two times the minimum
cut all the other cuts are completely
like are are are kep like the
approximation deals with that yes I can
throw away all the other Cuts just focus
on the cuts that are small these are the
ones which will almost always fail if
the graph needs
to okay and then there is this very
standard and and wellknown Lemma due to
carard that says that how many Cuts do I
have whose size is at most two * Lambda
it's only n to the four Cuts okay in
general if I have any multiplier Alpha
then the number of cuts of value at most
Alpha times Lambda is at most n ra to 2
Alpha so that says that I can take my
cut formula truncate to the first n to
the four terms if I'm ordering the cuts
by size truncate it and then now I have
a polinomial size formula on this just
apply the car Lu metas algorithm and
you'll have a reliability
algorithm now the problem of like the
catch of course is that I have this
condition that the unreliability is
smaller than n the minus 4 so what if
it's larger okay if the unreliability is
actually larger than n the minus 4 then
this the entire uh thesis doesn't work
right because the basic assumption that
the graph always fails at a small cut is
no longer true however this is actually
a very easy case as as Michael sort of
alluded to a little little earlier so
here you can just do monal sampling if
unrel if the graph getting disconnected
is not a elusive event it's it's
something you can actually observe in
polinomial time then of course we know
how to deal with such events how to
count such events so all you do is you
just create a bunch of samples so you
you just run the process of failing
edges that creates a sample of G of p on
that sample you define this uh the
indicator of whether the graph has
gotten connected and that's your
estimator repeat this a bunch of times
it's an unbiased estimator if you repeat
this about one over the unreliability
times then that will give you a good
estimation okay I mean this is just
standard statistics there's nothing
special okay so that's that's the entire
algorithm any questions about this
algorithm before we go to sort of the
second
generation yes is the part about having
all the is the part about having all the
um cuts listed in order is that
difficult uh no that's not difficult
it's it's it's it's easy to you can use
essentially any modification of a
minimum cut algorithm to enumerate all
Cuts that's at most
tce for example the contraction
algorithm that you might have
seen any other
questions
okay so that so that's as I said that
about the first generation of algorithms
and that brings us to the second
generation so the second generation of
algorithms for
unreliability uh the the first example
of that was this algorithm by carger in
2016 so for it gets exactly the same
sort of guarantees as the previous
algorithms except that it's faster it's
not Faster by a lot so remember the
harishon
sorry the Harrison trasan algorithm ran
in time about n cubed n cubed time some
subp polinomial term so this is this new
algorithm is replacing that subp
polinomial term by some polylog poly
logarithmic terms so it's a slight
Improvement but conceptually it's a big
leap and and and we'll see what what new
ideas it brings in and because it was
conceptually a big leap carger went on
in a couple of results to define the
running time initially from n cubed it
went down to n to the 2.78 and then all
the way to n squ so I want to mention
that these in the first step going from
n Cub to n to the 2.78 the algorithm
changed so it's the algorithm in fact
the one that I'll talk to you about the
one I'll present to you is the one that
was given in 2017 the one that gets into
to the 2.78 in the Second Step going
down from 2.78 to 2 that's exactly the
same algorithm it's just a better
analysis but in any case all of these
three use the same basic idea it uses it
in a more refined way in the later
algorithms but the basic idea is is
exactly the same and it's quite
different from what was happening in the
previous previous
generation so what is this basic idea so
if you remember um one of the B like
basic tools we have for a problem like
this is Monte Carlo sampling I want to
generate samples of this graph G of P
okay this is a random graph I want to
generate samples of this graph how do I
generate a sample of G of P now the knif
thing to do would be to say that I'll
take every Edge I'll toss a coin on the
edge with probability P The Edge goes
away with probability 1 minus P it stays
and that gives me a sample but let's
look at this process slightly
differently so let's assign an
independent random variable R sub e to
every Edge e
okay so I just toss a coin on every Edge
assign an independent
run now of course
it's the process that I outlined is
equivalent to saying that if the value
of our subb is smaller than P The Edge
should be deleted if it's larger than P
it should remain but now instead of
deleting any Edge let me do something
else let me take all the edges whose
value is larger than P so R subv is
larger than p and let me contract those
edges okay so earlier I was taking the
edges whose value is less than P
deleting them and trying to figure out
if the graph stays connected if there's
a single connected
component now I'm looking at the edges
that are preserved the ones that have
value larger than P I'm Contracting them
and now my test is is does the graph
collapse into a single vertex right if
there's a single connected component and
the edges get are contracted the graph
will collapse into a single
vertex so it's completely equivalent to
say that I'll contract edges with r subv
greater than p and check if the graph is
a single
vertex okay so here's an example so I
have these edges I'm drawing the edges
as ball the random variables
corresponding to the edges as walls and
then there is this threshold P
everything below this was being deleted
now I'm Contracting everything about
this
and of course my main challenge is that
the variance of this estimator is very
high when p is small it's just a Monte
Carlo estimator so the variance will be
very high even when p is
small so let me go in and artificially
reduce the variance how do I do
that so instead of just having this one
threshold P let me create an artificial
second threshold
Q now edges that are above the this all
the balls that that lie in this Zone
these edges I can safely contract
because even with the threshold P they
would be above the threshold so those
are edges that I can
contract edges that lie in this box I
really don't know what's going on with
them yet okay so what I do is I set this
threshold Q that's deliberately chosen
to be a larger threshold and contract
all the edges that appear above
q that generates a random graph for
me okay so how do I choose this Q it I
choose this Q basically morally in a way
that my variance remains
small take off the process and it turns
out that the right thing to do is to
choose Q roughly such that the value of
unreliability with Q is about 1 over n
squ let's just think of it as some
polinomial right I'm forcing my myself
to choose
a q such that the event of uh graph
disconnecting has polinomial probability
so it's a low variance event it's a it's
the kind of variance I can deal
with and I've gotten this graph H now
okay so I've contracted the the blue
edge so E3 has disappeared I've
contracted those and E1 and E4 are are
still there so I have this random
graph any guesses as to what I should be
doing on this graph now you order to
obtain an estimator for the original
problem sorry Rec recurse and that's
exactly what we do so we just take this
graph and recurse with the conditional
probability p over Q in this in this
smaller graph now what's the advantage
like at first glance it seems like well
I mean what am I really gaining by doing
it in two steps rather than doing it
directly the advantage and and of course
course I recurse and then I have to
repeat a bunch of times take averages
but that's just to kill the variance
okay that that's just
standard the
advantage is that H is much smaller than
G so this recursion the recursive call
is much more efficient so if you look at
this graph for instance the one that I
have the example I've drawn what
happened is that when E3 got contracted
The Edge E2 just vanished and I don't
even need to care about what's going on
in that edge and and of course this is a
very like small graph in general the
graph will get contracted into a much
smaller graph and on this smaller graph
I can run my recursion much more
efficiently so does does this remind
anyone of an algorithm that you have
seen for let's say for minimum
cut carstein exactly so this is the
exactly the same idea as in the
recursive contraction algorithm of
kerstein right
just being applied to a different
problem here but but basically the same
idea if you have seen
that any questions about this this
process okay and and and basically if
you do this the correct way uh do the
analysis correctly then then you can
show that this whole thing can be run in
B the same time as kerstein if you're
familiar with it in N Square time in
general all right so that's what you get
when you introduce this new idea the
recursive contraction idea into this
problem you get down to n squ but now
you hit what is sort of a basic
barrier and I'm calling that the
quadratic
barrier okay so what's this
barrier so it's clear that the
estimation of unreliability of U is
conceptually related to counting the
number of minimum cuts of the graph so
remember the basic idea in the first
generation of Al algorithms was to
truncate the cut formula at the small
Cuts in particular wherever you truncate
it must include all your minimum Cuts
that's the smallest value you have so it
seems like conceptually you really need
to be able to count minimum Cuts in
order to be able to estimate you in any
reasonable
approximation so counting of minimum
Cuts is hidden inside this problem in a
very deep conceptual
man now how are these algorithms
counting minimum
Cuts so in principle both the first and
second generation of algorithms they
count minimum cuts by
enumeration in the first generation it's
completely explicit it says that take
all these small cuts and I'll actually
write out a formula where I enumerate
all these Cuts so it's an explicit
enumeration of the minimum
Cuts second generation doesn't use
explicit enumeration it's a recursive
algorithm but if you are familiar with
the carstein recursive contraction
algorithm that can be used to enumerate
all the minimum Cuts as well so
explicitly or implicitly both of these
algorithms are counting Cuts small cuts
by enumeration it's going through the
list of cuts and that's how it ends up
counting
them that has a fundamental issue
because a graph can have N squared
minimum Cuts so if you're actually
counting via
enumeration then in a graph like a cycle
where that that has n squ min Cuts you
are stuck you can't go beyond n Square
time so that's a fundamental bottleneck
that these algorithms that are counting
by enumeration will
face okay so you need something new in
order to get past this quadratic
bound okay and that's that's what's
called the quadratic
barrier okay so so that now le leads me
to talk about the third generation of
algorithms and our new result uh so this
go breaks through the quadratic barrier
and it's exactly the same tradeoffs
except that we now have a running time
that's send to the three hes okay so we
are no longer bound by the N squ
barrier questions again about the
statement of the
result okay
okay so let's see what's going
on so as you can imagine the new
contribution that we have is a new
estimator for unreliability of course
all of these algorithms eventually are
are outputting estimators but we need a
new new type of an estimator now
something that's weaker than being able
to enumerate in
CS so the first uh theorem that we show
is that if your graph is not very
reliable so if the value of U is
relatively High let's say larger than n
to the
-3 then the previous techniques are are
going to actually do are are are already
very efficient so you can use some
combination of recursive contraction and
Monte Carlo sampling to get a runtime
that's the kind of desired runtime that
we want okay so it's not I'm not even
going to be talking about how to show
this theorem it needs some technical
work but the basic message is really we
should be focusing on the case where the
network is very very reliable right so
ugp is less than n to the -3 and
fundamentally in that case we show that
um recursive contraction and of course
Monte Carlo sampling both of these run
in at least and square time like it's
it's not just a matter of the analysis
not being sharp enough there are graphs
where it doesn't do any better
so we need something something
else sorry are you saying there's a like
a phase transition in the running time
at exactly this number uh
no so yeah so so for certain graphs
depends on what the graph is uh but if
you give me a graph that like a specific
like you can construct specific types of
graphs where
under when you become smaller than n to
the minus 3 I don't think there's a
phase like it's not a phase transition
our best analysis at the moment stops at
n to the -3 this negative result might
need a smaller value of you depending on
what the graph
is but uh but but there is a value of
you and a value and a and a particular
graph where if you run the previous
algorithms they will actually
takeen
yeah
uh is there an extension of this theorem
or basically is there anything special
about n the minus 3 or is it uh more
that if the there's a lower bound of say
Lambda on the probability of failure
then you can run in M plus root one over
Lambda time so the current analysis that
so these n to the three halves and N to
the minus like the threshold n to the3
and this running time and to the three
these are functions of the analysis that
we have in particular the first analysis
could could go down a bit possibly but
it can't go down any but what it won't
be able to show is that these techniques
get you better than n Square time no
matter what U is so the second thing is
saying that that's not possible there
there's I can give you a value of youu
and I can give you a graph where these
algorithms must take more
than so is the n to the three half
related to the N Cube the it is yes it
is it is
but but those values are functions of
our analysis right this n squ lower
bound is not a function of anything we
are doing it's just something about the
the previous algorithms being
fundamentally Stu
yeah sort of building on that if you're
looking at like U bigger than nus 2
instead or
something it could be in principle yes
it could be yes
other
questions
okay so our new contribution then is to
design a new estimator in this range
when uh the unreliability is smaller
than n to theed
3 okay so what do we do
here so the first observation is
something that was already there
something we have seen already in in in
the previous algorithms and this says
that if you have a very reliable graph
if your unreliability value is small
then you can discard cuts that are large
in particular for this particular
threshold n to the -3 it turns out that
we can discard cuts that are larger than
four *
Lambda okay so that's something that we
have seen already now here's one
interesting thing that's happening
now so what were we doing in the first
generation of algorithms we were
creating this dnf
formula why did you need to create a dnf
formula because there's some inclusion
Exclusion Principle going on in the
background right so I have these cuts
each cut fails with a certain
probability that's easy to calculate but
then the cuts overlap so their failure
uh is not
independent and therefore I need to
write this like complicated DNA formula
that Capt es the inclusion exclusion
phenomenon happening across the
cuts but notice that we are in very
reliable networks so already one cut
failing is a very uh unlikely event two
cuts failing is an even more unlikely
event so it turns out that if you are in
this range where U is less than n the -3
you don't need to do all this fancy
inclusion exclusion you can replace the
inclusion exclusion by simply a union
bound over the cuts so this will lose
some information it'll lose information
about multiple Cuts failing
simultaneously but that's a little of U
event probability event I don't care
about the small probabilities I'll
absorb that in the
approximation so that makes my life a
lot
simpler right now instead of writing
this complicated inclusion exclusion
based through a DNA formula what I can
simply do is I can take all my cuts for
every cut let's say cut C1 it's of size
uh whatever its size is I write a term
that's P raised to that size and then
sum up over all the
cuts moreover as I said I can discard
all Cuts larger than four times the Min
cut so in this sum I get rid of most of
the terms I only keep the terms going
from the Min Cuts two four times the Min
cuts and that's that's a new parameter
Z that I claimed through these two
observations approximates you up to some
little of one ter okay so all I care
about is estimating Z I don't care about
you
anymore questions about
this okay so I want to estimate Z how do
I go about doing
this so one thing to know noce that
although I have done all this truncation
and simplification the number of cuts
I'm dealing with is still quite large
right so I I'm dealing with cuts that
are of size four times the minimum cut
so the number of such Cuts can be
something like n to the8 so really I
have no hope of doing anything explicit
I can't actually like take all these
cuts and for each cut figure out what
this term is uh the P to the alpha
Lambda term is and sum them up any such
explicit processes is going to be very
slow so there's no hope for any
enumeration or explicit
algorithms so I need to do some sampling
right I need to estimate this parameter
via sampling I need to create an
estimator for
this now for this sampling what am I do
I want to do I want to sample cuts of
value at most four Lambda right I don't
want to sample other cuts that don't
contribute to my to my estimat to my
parameter so I really want to be
sampling these Cuts cuts that are whose
value is at most four times
Lambda uh and I want to use this
quantity P raised to the size of the cut
as the weight of a sampled cut somehow I
need to have an efficient sampling
technique that can do
this okay so that's that's our next goal
how do I sample a cut of this
size now what helps us here is um
this theorem this really old theorem by
Nash Williams and Tut that says the
following so if a graph has a Min cut of
Lambda so the smallest cut is a value
Lambda then of course it's clear that
the number of edge disjoints spanning
trees that I can construct in this graph
cannot exceed Lambda right because
whatever is the minimum cut it has to
contribute at least one Edge to each of
these spanning trees so the number of
edge destrin spanning
trees cannot exceed Lambda this theorem
gives a lower bound on this number it
says
that the maximum number of edge D span
increas is no more than Lambda but also
no less than Lambda / two you can think
of this as some kind of as an
approximate
Duality so if I had a graph of value
Lambda I know of Min cut Lambda I know
that I can construct Lambda over to
disjoint spanning
trees so that allows me to design the
following important sampling algorithm
so what I do is the following I
construct Lambda over 2 H destroy span
inrease now I should mention that
although I am describing it in this
these terms we don't explicitly do this
of course Lambda can be large I don't
have any way of actually explicitly
constructing these trees so we use some
implicit methods of sampling from these
trees but in principle think of
constructing these spanning
trees now once I've constructed the
spanning trees now think of a cut that
I'm trying to sample a cut of value at
most four times Lambda how many edges do
you expect to see in one of these
spanning trees from such a cut this cut
has four times Lambda edges there are
Lambda over two spanning trees these are
Edge disjoint so in expectation you
don't expect to see more than eight
edges in any one spanning tree so if I
chose a random spanning tree the
expected number of edges from from this
cut is no more than
eight so that allows me to think of the
following
surrogate so I'm not
sampling small Cuts anymore but I want
to sample cuts that have at most 8 edges
in a random spanning Tree in this
backing of course this is not the same
set of cuts but there is a one
directional
inclusion every cut that is small must
have a small number of FES in a random
spanning tree at least in
expectation so if I focus on just these
cuts that includes all the cuts that I
care about okay it might include a lot
of other Cuts many other Cuts might have
small number of edges in a spanning
tree okay and then if once I sample I
wait the sample by whatever is the
appropriate function like
P2 okay so this is the picture I had all
cuts and then I said because of of my uh
observation I could only focus on cuts
of value at most four Lambda so that's a
very small set of cuts now I am going to
these this larger set that sits between
these two sets that's all cuts that are
eight respecting a spanning tree eight
respecting just means that it has more
less than eight edges at most eight
edges okay so this is some sort of
surrogate set in the middle of these two
things and I'm sampling into that set I
have no way of sampling into this I
don't know how to do
that okay so the first observation and
is that the sampling algorithm can
actually be run very efficiently in
polog time per sample uh as I said
there's no hope of actually constructing
any spanning trees and so on but but you
can do like there are tricks to make
this run
fast the more sort of conceptually
interesting question is what if the
measure of the useful Cuts so this like
dark blue Cuts or the purple Cuts what
if that measure is really small compared
to this light blue set like it's
possible this is a small set inside
right so I can sample into this light
blue set but I'll really not hit this
set so it's not very useful for me so
how do I deal with this
problem now if this is the case then
there are very few small Cuts in the
graph what that means is that if I look
at pairs of vertices different pairs of
vertices most pairs are very well
connected it's a very small number of
small Cuts so most pairs are well
connected there are a few pairs that are
weakly
connected so in this case what we do is
we go to uh the well-connected pairs
pairs that cannot be separated by a
small cut and just contract them I don't
really care right these if I have a pair
of vertices whose pairwise connectivity
the number of edges that are in any cut
separating that particular pair if
that's let's say 10 Lambda then really
any of those interesting Cuts cannot
separate that pair so why don't I just
contract that pair and
continue and and we can do this
efficiently using something called a g
hoot tree that that I don't need to
describe
here okay so once you put all of these
together then we get this so in very
reliable networks we show that there is
an estimator for this quantity Z which
is a surrogate for U uh that can be
computed in this time in time that's
about into the three Hales put that
together with the with the theorem I
mentioned earlier in less reliable
networks previous techniques can already
be made to speed up to the same running
time and once you put all that together
you you get this result of n the
3 okay so let me end with a couple of
open question questions uh the most
obvious one that immediately arises is
like where did this n to the three
halves come from is this even natural it
seems like the way that we are doing the
analysis and the algorithms that we are
using n to the three Hales is a real
Bound for that so it's um it's not that
like some slight modifications will
improve it to a linear time but it's
possible that the principle that we
introduced in this third sort of
generation of algorithms it's possible
that that will eventually lead to a near
linear time
algorithm and of course the field of
network uh reliability algorithms sort
of Beyond this one specific problem I
told you about is essentially completely
open yes so even as I said even this
very basic question I give you a graph
every Edge fails with probability half
what's the probability that s and t are
connected even this basic question
there's there's nothing more that's all
thank
you
[Applause]
so a couple of questions
so is it implicit in your results
already I don't think so but but I'm
hoping that you can do otia of M plus
the number of Min Cuts
suppose um no so so the sort of bad
examples tend to be ones where there's
just one Min cut but then a fairly large
number of cuts that's slightly larger
than the minimum okay so o plus M plus
the number of Min cuts that are within a
factor of two yeah something like that
probably
yes I would think so okay um and and I'm
just curious because I guess I haven't
followed the literature well enough how
do you do gy who in theine near time oh
that's a that's a new result that we
have a separate result okay not near
linear that's almost linear yeah okay
other
questions um is there a hope of some
parts of this being
deterministic that's a good question I
don't know of any deterministic
algorithms even I think the ones for the
special cases are not deterministic
like I mean I don't think anything rules
it out it's just that I I don't
know at the beginning you promised to
make some remarks on reliability as well
good so thanks for reminding me so um so
reliability is a very different problem
in the approximation world and in fact
the first polinomial time approximation
scheme came 20 years after the
unreliability work uh so this is a paper
by I think guo and jam and they use mcmc
methods so Mark of CH Monte Carlo
methods and there's a whole line of work
that's followed on after that initial
result of speeding up those techniques
but but it goes in in in a completely
different
direction if there are no more questions
let's thank the speaker
again and we have a break until